before I go I want to share this story
with you because it's important to this
point
I want your community to know that one
of the coolest people I ever met
is transgender woman and this is not a
man that I knew that became a woman this
woman was trans when I met her lived in
San Francisco Daphne dwarman is a name
I would do 18 shows in the Bay Area
sometimes in Oakland and dirty Hood
nightclub and she would be there white
trans woman laughing loud and hard at
everything I said especially the trans
jokes it's very puzzling
because she was obviously trans
and one night after one of the shows I
met up
and what it was
turns out
it was her dream to be a comedian and I
was a hero
it's very moving I could not dislike
somebody that felt that way about me we
became Fast Friends
and when I made that special Sticks and
Stones right as it was coming out I
happened to be in San Francisco and I
wanted to do a show but I needed an
opening act and I remembered
that trans woman I've met so I called
her on the phone
and and I called her myself I said hey
Daphne this is Dave Chappelle she
couldn't believe it
and I go I'm in San Francisco and then
she started saying a bunch of wild stuff
I was like relaxed now I don't want any
[__] I was um
it's calling because I'm doing a show
and I I need an opening act
and I was wondering if you'd open the
show and she was like [__] yeah now
I didn't know this at the time
but but this woman had only done
stand-up comedy eight times in her life
this is little to no experience and now
she's about to open a show for what many
called The Goat
she's an amateur and stature but in
practice she was very professional
she showed up early which is something I
appreciate because I like people to be
on time she was dressed to the
[__] nines I mean I'm
transphobic and even I was like you look
nice
went up on the stage with all the swag
of a professional comedian grab that mic
and walk right down the middle and
looked at the crowd like a gangster man
you should have seen her work
speech bombed for 45 minutes straight
and I am not exaggerating young man that
show was terrible
stalker
stunk
and then she brings me on and you know
you know I was like a glass of water
after a handful of salt the crowd was
happy to see me I was killing it
but here's what impressed me
any other comedian I've ever seen if
they had bombed as bad as she did would
have snuck out of the back of the
theater and went home and cried or
something and she didn't do that not
only did she not leave she found a seat
right up in front you know when a new
comedian watches an experienced comedian
and comedy we call this taking class and
this [__] took my whole class she sat
up there and was laughing as hard as she
always laughs as if nothing bad had even
happened to her and I saw her show
something bad happened to her
foreign
she was drunk
so she starts talking to me while I'm on
stage but the way a person would talk to
a television when they were alone she
was talking to me like that didn't
bother me because I knew him but the
crowd didn't like that [__] at all
because she sucked
and a guy in the back of the room stood
up
Daphne's hair was dyed blonde at the
time and the guy screamed out and his
Energy felt wild as [__] he said hey
Daphne and everybody kind of clamped
that got tense we didn't know it was a
Heckler or active shooter and
he said he said
does the carpet match the drapes
hey it was [__] up the whole crowd
kind of grown because it was so like
mean everybody grown except for Daphne
she kind of laughed which was weird and
she didn't even look all the way back
she said sir I don't have carpets I have
hardwood floors just like that
just like that
boy when she said that [__] it blew the
roof off the place
cut through all the tension with that
one joke she made up for 45 minutes of a
stinker of a show
and after that she could do no wrong and
I kept on rocking she kept on talking to
me and then the show
became something cooler than a show
she became like a conversation between a
black man and a white trans woman and we
started getting to the bomber ship all
them questions that you think about that
you'd be afraid to ask I was just asking
them and she was answering them and her
answers were funny as [__] the crowd was
falling out of the chairs and and at the
end of the show I go oh Daphne I said
well that was fun I go I go I love you
to death but I have no [__] idea what
you're talking about the whole crowd
laughed
except for Daphne now she looks at me
like I'm not her friend anymore like I'm
something bigger than me like I'm the
whole world and the guy and she said I
don't need you to understand me I said
what
she said I just need you to believe just
like this she goes that I'm having a
human experience
and when she said it
the whole crowd kind of gasps
and I gave her the fight club look
I said I believe you [__]
because she didn't say anything about
pronouns
she didn't say anything about me being
in trouble she said just believe I'm a
person and I'm going through it you know
I believe you because it takes one to
know one
[Applause]
foreign
good night and they start going crazy
before the Applause gets to his
Crescendo I say and don't forget my
opening act Daphne
the crowd stood up
and I looked at the tears came out of my
eyes she couldn't believe it was
happening
I couldn't believe what's happening
because their show stuck
it was a great night I remember the late
great Paul Mooney was there a bunch of
fly-ass Comedy [__] was there
[Applause]
and we all went backstage and was just
drinking and talking [__] and laughing
and dancing he stole the room she had
everyone cracking up spinning the yarn
telling us all these crazy stories about
[__] she be into
we all laughing real hard and then she's
telling us and everyone's laughing
looking around I'm like oh my God she is
funny
I pulled her a sign I said you're
hilarious I didn't know that when you
were on stage
I said you're doing some things wrong
but I can help you I said anytime I'm in
San Francisco why don't you open the
show for me and I'll just try to give
you some point and see if you can't work
this thing out and she said are you
serious
he's like yeah and she grabbed me real
tight huggling squeezing and I pushed
her off violently because I'm
transphobic I said boundaries [__]
[Applause]
when Sticks and Stones came out
a lot of people in the trans Community
were furious with me and apparently they
dragged me on Twitter I don't give a
[__] because Twitter's not a real place
and the hardest thing for a person to do
is go against their tribe if they
disagree with their tribe but Daphne did
that for me
she wrote a tweet that was very
beautiful and what she said was there's
almost exactly what she said
she said punch him down on someone
requires you to think less of them and I
know him and he doesn't
he doesn't punch up he doesn't punch
down he punches lines and he's a master
at his crafts that's what she said
beautiful three beautiful friend that
took a lot of heart to defend me like
that and when she did that the trans
Community
dragged that [__] all over Twitter
for days they was going in on her and
she was on her own because she's funny
but six days after that wonderful night
I described to you my friend Daphne
killed herself
oh yeah it's true story my heart was
broken
yeah it wasn't the jokes I don't know if
it was them Dragon I don't know what's
going on in her life but I bet dragging
her didn't help
I was very angry with them I was very
angry at her
I felt like Daphne lied to me she always
said she identified as a woman and then
one day she goes up to the roof of a
building and jumps off and kills herself
clearly
only a man would do some gangster [__]
like that
hear me out
as hard as it is to hear a joke like
that I'm telling you right now Daphne
would have loved that joke that's why
she was my friend
foreign
[Music]
and I found out she was survived by a
daughter
uh and the moment I found that out and
this is true Anderson Cooper from CNN
texted me
and all he said was very nice he said
I'm sorry to hear about your friend
and I texted him right back a new phone
who this
he said it's Anderson Cooper I said oh I
said Anderson I go look I need to find
her family and he texted me right back
with all the phone numbers and all this
information I say this and say if you
ever want to know about anything gay
call Anderson Cooper from CNN this [__]
is faster than Google
and what I did is I got in touch with
the family and I started a trust fund
for her daughter because I know that's
all she ever really cared about
and I don't know what the trans
community did for her but I don't care
because I feel like she wasn't their
tribe she was mine she was a comedian
and her soul
your daughter is very young but I hope
to be alive
when she turns 21 because I'm going to
give her this money myself
and by then
by then I'll be ready to have the
conversation that I'm not ready to have
today but I'll tell that little girl
young lady
I know your father
and he was a wonderful woman
[Applause]